it avec nos invités françois costantini
géopolitologue et morad el hattab
écrivain et géopolitologue bonsoir à
vous remercier d'être avec moi en direct
sur arte france
cette visite d' emmanuel macron toute la
journée au liban est ce que vous pensez
qu'à l'heure où justement la solidarité
internationale s'organise c'est une
visite opportune pour je pense qu'elle
s'inscrit dans la ligne en effet des
relations privilégiées entre la france
et le liban l etat marqueur en effet ce
qu'il faut c'est et c'est que l'on ne
savait pas une pure passe une
communication qu'elles soient suivies
d'effets quand effet cette conférence se
tienne dans les meilleurs moments et que
l'aide organisé soit conséquente durable
longue qu'elle s'inscrive peut-être
au-delà de l'aide d'urgence de la
catastrophe et que surtout qu'elle passe
à travers le gouvernement libanais qui
aujourd'hui totalement discrédité par la
population libanaise en général et
beyrouthine en particulier et qu'en
effet on aide les libanais mais pas le
liban officiel en quelque sorte l
attaque parce que vous vous partagez cet
avis également c'était nécessaire de
voir aujourd'hui emmanuel macron dans la
capitale libanaise
après cette effroyable
explosion mardi dernier on va rejoindre
tout à l'heure morad el hattab on est un
petit souci de liaison avec lui on vous
retrouve donc françois costantini on va
poursuivre avec vous en attendant de
rétablir à la liaison avec mourad est la
table justement cette visite elle est
vue d'une certaine manière par la classe
politique française comme
de l'opportunisme aussi de l'apparat du
président français qu'en pensez vous
chaque homme tel que les hommes
politiques en particulier en général et
même maquereau en particulier sont un
calcul médiatique dans un certain nombre
de posture il est certain qu'il faut pas
que cette livi cette limite de quelques
heures se limite à un certain nombre de
clichés sinon l'effet sur les
catastrophiques et fortement déplaisant
je crois pour le peuple libanais qui a
pas besoin de ça donc il faut tout cela
soit suivi d'effets je rappelle qu'il ya
quelques jours avant l'explosion le
drame de beyrouth
jean yves le drian mille affaires
étrangères européennes étaient à pérou
où justement elle va il évoquait la cité
de ce qu'il appelle des réformes de la
part du gouvernement libanais pour que
celui ci bénéficie à nouveau d'une aide
internationale de nouveaux prêts de nous
votons donc il faut de façon conséquent
je pense à la communauté internationale
se penche sur le cas du liban sur le cas
particulier dans lequel se trouve le
liban avec notamment la présidence d
intérêt reggio la des intérêts régionaux
antagonismes dans le liban est depuis
trop longtemps la cible avec également
la prévenance du hezbollah dont il
faudra bien parler un jour sur le pays
et le fait que en effet le hezbollah
soit deux jours de moins de façon
indirecte mis en cause dans temps les
malheurs que traverse aujourd'hui le
liban mais le liban n'est pas le seul
mais pas seul il ya également sa tombe
de de danger islamiste qui ne sont pas
qui ne sont pas sont pas des moindres et
je pense qu'il faudra que la communauté
internationale se penche définitivement
sur sur le liban de façon durable
je crois morad el hattab qui est
maintenant bien en liaison avec nous un
mourad el hattab comment vous vous avez
jugé cette visite dans l'urgence du
président français justement dans
l'urgence sens que l'urgence pour les
libanais et existe depuis février 2019
c'est pour ça que je suis assez surpris
qu aujourd'hui on est à évoquer autant
la politique intérieure libanaise
puisque vous savez comme moi que la
priorité d'abord c'est un cheminement
humanitaire la reconstruction dans les
faits actuels du liban ce à peu près 50
milliards de dollars
là on parle de 10 donc on est loin du
compte ce qui me chagrine un peu c'est
que effectivement elle a très bien
rappelé notre ami géopolitique
on a un devoir d'amitié avec le liban on
n'a pas un devoir d'ingérence
et effectivement les postures adoptées
aujourd'hui me gêne énormément je tiens
à rappeler comme que le les le liban
n'est pas une ancienne colonie française
la protectorat qui est indépendant et
souverain depuis 1943 et par rapport aux
acteurs régionaux
je vous le dis de boudin blanc ce qu'ils
règleront réellement un problème en
terme de politique intérieure ce sont
l'arabie saoudite et l'iran et et en
arrière-plan les états unis et la russie
on essaye et monsieur concertina
rappeler via une la venue du ministre
des affaires étrangères pas plus tard
que récemment au liban
il n'en est pas sorti des grands
résultats et puis par ailleurs il ya un
point qui est très important on nous
parle d'une explosion
or personne n'a déterminé à ce jour
c'était une explosion ou un attentat en
france a constaté dit sur l'ingérence va
trois points de vue le liban depuis trop
longtemps depuis pratiquement comme l'a
rappelé monsieur adam 1943 il a été le
sujet d ingérence notamment la ligue
arabe la présence des palestiniens qui a
été une une meurtrissure pour le liban
qui est à l'origine de la guerre ensuite
le jeu israélien la présence de la syrie
et la tutelle syrienne pendant 15 ans et
puis en suisse est ce de sortie de la
syrie en 2005 avec un en fait en toile
de fond un renforcement au final du rôle
du hezbollah il se lie banques on a
utilisé un peu comme un appât dans la
bouche la syrie comme carotte et un
bâton à l'égard de la syrie les états
unis il faut pas l'oublier en 76 ont
fait rentrer la syrie au liban et en
2005 parce qu'elle ne rentrait plus dans
leurs plans le mans d2 sortir donc ils
vont y croire qu'un jour
on s'interroge sur l'ensemble de
l'ingérence et qu'on en outre alice de
façon durable le lit blanc au plan
régional parce que je pense que un pays
comme le liban c'est à la fois un pays
qu'on dit trop souvent fragile mais
c'est un pays également prometteur avec
cette cohabitation paritaire de l'islam
et de la chrétienté au liban dans le
monde qu'on connaît aujourd'hui je pense
c'est plutôt ça qu'on devrait protéger
et essai c'est en effet les jeunes gens
extérieurs qui met aujourd'hui en péril
le modèle libanais sans l'ingérence je
reprends un peu les termes de morad el
hattab je pense qu'il faisait allusion à
la visite des manuels macron et
l'ingérence française
si vous permettez quelque chose de vrai
et là où il prête à sourire
c'est la fameuse promesse de saint-louis
bon lorsqu'il parle du pacte entre
l'islam et le christianisme
mais là où je viens je veux ajouter aux
propos il a effectivement tout à fait
raison le liban est aujourd'hui le pays
qui compte au niveau mondial le plus
grand nombre de réfugiés par rapport à
sa population
donc effectivement à sa cause problème
on a à peu près deux millions de
réfugiés et syriens palestiniens sur le
sol libanais il faudra bien sûr régler
cette solution mais je tiens quand même
à rappeler que le liban dans sa
structure aujourd'hui est un casino
il importe 80% de ses biens il faut
savoir que justement dans le cadre d'une
reconstruction du liban
il faudra peut-être réfléchir aussi à
une auto gérance libanais enfin
autosuffisance libanaise en termes
d'agriculture d'industrie peut pas
rester une banque offshore assez ouvert
on rappelle que la destruction justement
du port c'est la destruction de 60% en
tout cas du transit d'importation
concernant le liban lefrançois
constantine et si vous voulez bien
répondre sur l'ingérence présumé
française au liban aujourd'hui c'est
avec cette visite d' emmanuel macron je
pense que si il ya eu ingérence qui a
été à mon avis la plus douce et la plus
acceptable
c'est quand même c'est quand même la
gérance française parce que ça a été
mais c'était pas une c'est un protocole
ans n'est pas un protectorat c'est un
mandat en fait c'était un mandat qui
était donné par le site et des nations
pour amener le liban
et moi moi je la fis en main on peut me
contredire j'ai fait une thèse dessus
j'ai fait quand même que les années 1920
1940 trois ont été pour moi des années
de bonheur pour le liban parce que la
france il ya construit comme
d'institutions y aller la démocratie il
ya un et l'égalité entre toutes les
communautés je rappelle que avant les
chrétiens vivaient dans un état
d'infériorité dans la région par rapport
à l'islam politique
ils sont sortis la dhimmitude il ya une
parité également entre entre entre
chrétiens et musulmans alors le système
confessionnel il peut être critiquable
je suis tout je suis tout à fait
d'accord là dessus
moi je suis pour un confessionnalisme
rationaliser serre que il doit s'arrêter
à l'équilbre au sein de l'état mais au
niveau de la population
on doit recruter de façon sur le mérite
et fonctionnaires et non pas en fonction
de deux critères confessionnels en effet
il faudra rationaliser le
confessionnalisme à mon autre laïcisé
certains espaces il n'est pas normal par
exemple que des libanais de confession
différente à israël se marier à chypre
mais monsieur a tout à fait raison
lorsqu'il parle de taux de suffisance le
liban pour moi avec la plaine de la
békaa est largement autosuffisante en
agroalimentaire il peut même exporter il
a en effet une des plaines et les plus
fertiles du proche orient
c'est un état qui a toutes les vérités
en effet pour être taux suffisant et
pour exporter au au plan alimentaire
mais ça c'est un problème général vous
savez de conception des échanges
mondiaux globaux et le fait que
aujourd'hui on soit réticent à tout idée
d'un protectionnisme intelligent
rationaliser qui permettrait de revenir
à un certain modèle modèle autocentré et
c'est en effet c'est également la
neutralisation des blancs parce que ce
liban trop ouvert c'est l'extérieur des
dépendants en effet la tomme extérieur
on voit ce que ça donne aujourd'hui et
il faut pour moi que le peuple le
développement se fasse au service du
peuple libanais alors vous parlais tout
à l'heure du hezbollah d' 2
et justement emmanuel macron lui il a
tenté de parler en tout cas de lancer un
message à toutes les forces politiques
aux dirigeants libanais la balle est
dans le camp c'est ce qu'a dit en fait
elles manuel macro effectivement la
france peut appuyer une certaine
solidarité internationale mais la balle
est vraiment dans le camp des dirigeants
libanais morad el hattab est ce que
véritablement il ya un pacte politique
possible au liban c'est ce que demande
emmanuel macron avec la situation
actuelle les relations rôle c'est entre
les autorités le hezbollah tout ça est
très compliqué oui d'abord d'abord il
est bon de rappeler que au liban il ya
eu des élections et les libanais ont
choisi parce que on fait comme si
sorti du chapeau des mouvements
politiques non c'est le choix du peuple
libanais les libanais sont pas venus
contester nos élus récent avec 60% de
taux d'abstention bon parce que ça je
tiens à rappeler qu néanmoins
deuxièmement effectivement la présence
du hezbollah est une présence forte
importante au liban elle fait le jeu
dans le sens où c'est aussi une force
armée bien plus armé que l'armée des
gîtes hymne d'ibanez donc ça va c'est
j'ai presque envie de dire vous pouvez
pas faire le liban aujourd'hui sans le
hezbollah et puis par ailleurs c'est ce
que je tenais à dire dès le départ c'est
que ceux qui sont les réels levier du
règlement interne au liban sont
effectivement l'iran qui finissent qui
financent à hauteur de 700 millions de
dollars par an le hezbollah et l'arabie
saoudite dans le sens où il faudra
trouver devront s'asseoir à une table et
trouver un compromis où il y aura en
arrière plan les états unis et la russie
aujourd'hui la france c'est un voeu
pieux que qu'annonce emmanuel macron et
je vous dis encore une fois même sur le
plan financier
ça ne répond pas aux attentes de la
reconstruction du liban ça c'est un
premier point
et puis aussi injuste une chose que je
voulais rajouter notre ami a très
justement justifier la plaine des cas il
faut ajouter aussi un autre point
essentiel c'est la découverte
deux gisements gaziers sur les côtes
libanaises permettra aussi une autre
suffisant sur le plan énergétique parce
qu'on n'arrête pas de parler des
problèmes de santé et autres
le liban peut régler aussi ce problème
françois costantini on va conclure
justement le cette solidarité
internationale qui s'exprime on voit des
acteurs qui sont mauvaises relations
normalement avec le liban c'est le cas
d'israël c'est le cas de l'iran exprimer
leur solidarité est ce que finalement il
ya quelque chose qui peut sortir de ce
drame
quelque chose de positif qui peut
permettre justement à la région de deux
de sortir de cet imbroglio géopolitique
dans lequel il est plat est ce qui
chacun était de bonne foi
si je vous ai dire si l'iran au-delà de
ces messages de soutien arrêtez
peut-être de considérer le liban comme
ça pointe avancée dans ses intérêts
selon lequel le hezbollah
si israël en effet arrêté un peu son jeu
cynique montrant qu'elle n'a jamais même
système anti confessionnel au liban et
qu'elle verrait bien le liban être une
terre d'implantation des palestiniens ce
qui ce qui ne saurait être les cas ce
qui est rejeté par la quasi totalité de
la population libanaise bien peut-être
qu'on avancera elle mais encore faut-il
que tous ces acteurs régionaux notamment
notamment ceux que vous avez cités soit
bonne foi et arrête de faire du liban le
champ clos de l'or
de leur antagonisme réciproque pour vous
à morad el hattab
ben moi je dis que je bénéficie de
toutes les ressources humaines et on le
voit aussi énergétiques et agricoles
pour redevenir commune la cité tout à
l'heure entre 1920 et 234 ce qu'on
appelait la suisse du moyen-orient merci
merci à vous françois costantini je
rappelle que vous êtes géopolitologue
morad el hattab écrivain et
géopolitologue